You know, for any of you Google hackers there, I'm sure this guy went through and totally milked
all of this. And you should definitely not look for any of the ones that he missed using App Script.
And you should also definitely not diff the App Script docs to make sure when new functions are
added that you can't be abused to do something similar. I think that's probably a waste of time
because this guy definitely found everything, as all testers do.
What's up, hackers? So Zero Trust World just happened and Threat Locker dropped some pretty cool stuff.
My favorite of the bunch was Threat Locker Cloud Control, and I'll tell you why. Okay.
So when you're trying to hack an organization nowadays, what's kind of like the go-to approach?
Well, for most, it's going to be set up Evil Engine X and send out a bunch of phishing emails, right?
That way you don't have to worry about two-factor authentication or anything like that because
Evil Engine X is just going to let them put in their password, their 2FA, and then just hand you
back a session token to interact with Microsoft 365. So Threat Locker realized this was a problem.
And so what they decided to do was build Cloud Control, which uses the Threat Locker agent
to sync into Microsoft Cloud Conditional Access, a list of approved IP addresses from which a user
can connect, right? So then an attacker gets that token that they stole by Evil Engine X. They try to
use it to interact with Microsoft 365, and boom, they're burned because they're not coming from a
permitted network and they lose access. It's pretty sick. It's a great solution to the problem.
So definitely check it out, Threat Locker Cloud Control. All right, back to the show.
Ladies and gentlemen, boys and girls, hackers, this kind of week is the week that makes the
podcaster, let me tell you. Our boy Rezo is out sick and I have been in a wedding all weekend as one
of our close friends was getting married and we are the primarily responsible party. And it is now 2.30 on
a Sunday when this podcast was due on a Thursday and I'm still showing up for you guys. Hopefully
that shows how much I love you guys. So we're just going to do a quick little solo episode this week.
We're going to run through some research and we're going to call it a week, but I had to give you guys
something to listen to, right? You know, I can't disappoint my listeners. So yeah, and shout out to the
production team for dealing with my late missing the deadlines. Thanks, Richard. Thanks, Christian.
Appreciate you guys. All right. So let's, let's get into the research this week. We're going to cover
four pieces of research. We're going to cover, um, Ports Wiggers, uh, Samuel Roulette that they just
released. We're going to cover three, uh, Google reports that just got disclosed, uh, with some cool
attack vectors in them. And then finally, we're going to wrap it up with this next JS corrupt middleware
research that just dropped a couple of days ago, which is like crazy. Um, all right, let me get some
water. Let's jump into it. All right. So first up, let's look at Samuel Roulette. This is a, once again,
an awesome piece of research that was released by the Ports Wigger research team, Gareth and, um, one of
the other researchers, uh, that who's listed around here somewhere. Where is he? Zach. Yep. Um, and this was
unfortunately a research collision with Alexander Tan, a hacker one who I've mentioned several times on the
podcast. She was kind of like the Samuel God. I've reached out to them and said, Hey, could you like
come on the pod? And they said, sure. Uh, let me just get some CVS disclosed. So if you're listening
to this, Alexander, now's your time, man, come on, let's go, let's get on the pot. Um, but I'm definitely
going to ping him after this one because it's, uh, it's pretty sick. Um, but yeah, let's kind of go
through this specific attack. This was a, uh, Samuel bypass completely in Ruby Samuel affecting
Git lab unauthenticated, uh, account takeover. Um, and it was pretty awesome. So this type of attack
comes from a technique called round trip attacks. And I'll read this one line from the, from the
write up here, which, uh, describes it pretty well. Samuel libraries often parse an XML document,
store it as a string, and then later reparse it in Ruby Samuel. This process involves two different
parsers re XML, which is used to parse the document and validate the signature and no code GIDI, which is
used to access, uh, attributes. And that should be sending alarm bells off in your head, right?
Because, uh, anytime there's sort of like this double parsing environment, then there's chance,
there's a chance that there will be discrepancies. And that's exactly what the ports of your research
team manipulated in this specific environment. So, uh, how did they do that exactly? Well,
they came up with this excellent payload, which is being shared on the screen for any of you who are
following along on, on YouTube, but, uh, this is a podcast. So I will also say it out loud. Um,
essentially what's happening here is they present a, uh, XML document that has a single quoted attribute,
uh, in it. And this attribute contains, uh, an XML comment and, uh, some entity, uh, entities inside of it.
Um, and essentially what, what happens then is when this document is parsed the first time,
the single quoted attribute will be parsed as an attribute, but then when it's put, you know,
stored as a string, like we said in the first part, that single quoted attribute becomes a double
quoted attribute. Well, that's a problem because the first attribute, uh, had a double quote in it.
So that would close the, uh, double quoted attribute that was being, uh, converted from the single quote,
and then allow you to specify, uh, various, uh, other tags and comments and stuff like that.
So what they did here is they specified a comment and were able to insert a malicious assertion into
this animal response, which then gets picked up by the, um, the auth engine later and used to determine
which user should be logged in. Um, so essentially what they're doing here is they're using attribute
manipulation. They're using a double quote or a single quoted attribute. And then when it's
converted into a double quote attribute, it does something different to the, to the XML document.
Um, very cool stuff there. And it definitely makes sense that that would be happening when there's two
different parsing engines being used to affect the XML there. Um, so that's kind of the TLDR of the
first part. You can read, uh, more thoroughly, uh, on the actual writeup if you'd like, but the idea was
double parse the XML document and then have a, you know, some data that is in a attribute in the first
time around that is not in an attribute the second time around allowing us to insert some malicious,
uh, XML, but the attack gets a little bit more difficult than that because, um, of a couple factors.
One, uh, you know, they kind of want, uh, arbitrary unauthenticated account takeover, right?
Um, but the way that this works is they need to provide a, uh, a valid signature for them to go through
the first signature check, uh, XML document parsing, right? So they said, you know, in the beginning,
let me see if I can find that quote. They said that, uh, this process involves due to do different
parsers re XML, which is used to parse the document and validate the signature and no code, which is
used to access attributes. Okay. So re in order to get past that first one, the re XML, they have to
provide a valid signature to their, their SAML response endpoint. Right. Um, and one of the ways that
they did that was super cool, um, is that they used this metadata endpoint that was associated with,
uh, the, the XML environment. Let me see if I can pull it up here. Um, yes, right here. It says,
finding a valid, uh, signed XML document can be challenging. Fortunately, the identity providers
silently provide a single sign on protocol. WS federation by default for every tenant. WS federation
provides signed metadata XML endpoints such as this, and they link to an XML endpoint. So
essentially what they're able to do is hit this metadata endpoint that is signed. And then because
that has a valid signature on it, they can reuse that signature to pass bypass that first part and
then utilize the, uh, attribute discrepancies to, uh, insert their own, um, uh, assertion into the,
the XML document on the second parse through. So very creative attack factors here. The other piece
that I kind of wanted to mention on this one that I kind of skipped over for a second was how exactly
they got it to look at their assertion versus the assertion, uh, that was originally provided in
the document. And the way that they did that was by using something that I had never seen before in
XML. Let me see if I can find it here in the document. Yeah, here it is right here. Um, which
is a, you know, we, we all know about entities being defined in, in doc type, right? That's how you do
traditional, uh, XML entity attacks. Um, but what I hadn't known is that you can specify other types of,
uh, objects as well inside the doc type. You can specify, um, attributes, entities, and
elements, right? So those, those three elements, attributes, entities. And if you think about it,
that's kind of what makes up an XML document, uh, or if you even think about it from HTML, which is
sort of a, a tweak of XML, you know, you've got your, your, your elements, you've got your tags,
right? You've got the attributes for those tags, and then you've got these entities, right? You know,
your dollar dollar sign or your ampersand sign, and then the entity, and then the semicolon, right?
So it's, it's cool that you can define all, all three of those inside of the doc type. And it just,
when I was thinking about this, when I was researching it, it kind of made me realize a
little bit more, wow. Okay. I kind of feel like I have a better grip on XML now that I know what this
doc type is used for. And it is being used to define these various elements. Um, so what they ended
up doing here was, um, they, they looked at the, the way that, uh, Nokogiri was checking for the, uh,
the signature piece. Uh, I'm sorry, not Nokogiri. This is, uh, the, the one that is, uh, RE XML,
search for the signature element. And the way that it does that is that it does a, uh, expath selector
on a specific, uh, attribute. So it hits, it looks for DS signature and it looks for the, uh, DS
attribute to point to XML, DSIG. Um, so then what, what they did is they changed what, uh, what assertion
would have that, um, using that uncommented out, uh, uh, attribute, right? So then when the attribute
went from single quote to double quote, they applied a doc type ATT list, which is as opposed to a doc type
entity, they, they used the bang ATT list, um, define to define a specific value for, uh, the XML NS
attribute on the signature block, which allowed them to sort of hijack, um, which of the assertions
or which signature, excuse me, um, it should be looked at, uh, at different times in the document.
So, um, really, really creative, uh, technique here to take advantage of the fact that they have
the ability to modify the XML document essentially after, uh, it's being parsed using, uh, document
types. They use that to insert a, uh, an attribute to a specific signature that they, that they wanted,
um, which was a really, really creative technique. And so I kind of went down the, the, um, the rabbit
hole a little bit when I was researching this and reading through it. And, you know, I figured out
that there was elements, attributes, and entities, but then I also found this really, really weird,
um, uh, image and Christian, I'm gonna, I've got it in the doc. So just go ahead and put that up on
the screen, the use of elements versus attributes. Um, there's this picture that I, that I took from
the docs that says, apparently data can be stored in a child element or in an attribute. So if you have
something like the example that they gave here was they have a person tag in XML, right? And they have
sex equals female. And then they've got, you know, additional data about that person, such as their
first name and last name in the XML document, and they close off the person tag, right? So the,
the sex for the person is defined in the, uh, attribute. And then they said, this is an
equivalent document. And they say, person, uh, close the tag. And then inside that there's another
tag that has sex that has first name, that is last name. And then you close the person tag.
And apparently you can use attributes and sub elements interchangeably in XML, which I was like,
what? That seems super whack. Um, so yeah, anytime you have an attribute on a tag,
you can also specify that attribute as a sub tag of the tag that the attribute should have been on,
which seems a little bit weird to me. And I'm sure there's weird shit out there that, uh, you know,
takes advantage of that fact. So definitely check that out if you're interested in XML,
um, or XML confusions, that sort of thing. Um, all right, let me take a look at my notes really quick
here and make sure I didn't forget about anything else. Yeah. I mean, I would just say,
everybody who is interested in XML, you should take a look at how doc types work. I just read the WW or
W3 schools, um, sort of write-ups on how they work. And there's some really interesting stuff in there
that isn't sort of surface level, what you would think about when you think about doc types. Um, so
I definitely recommend that. All right. Solo episode guys. So I don't get the chance to take,
you know, a breather while, while Joseph's talking and I, so I got to get my water real
quick before we move on to the next one. All right. So this next write-up, um, that I kind of
wanted to cover with you guys, let me give a little bit of context to this. So the Google, um,
VRP does have disclosed reports, but they don't get disclosed very often. And recently they just kind
of did a batch release of some of the reports from 2024. So I kind of went through and skimmed through
each one of them and tried to find the ones that had the coolest attack vectors to it. Um,
and I'll go ahead and kind of go through those now with you guys and, uh, and just kind of give
you the TLDR on what you could take away from those. So this one right here is entitled loophole of
getting Google form associated with Google sheets with no editor slash owner access. So essentially,
um, this is a way for you to take the Google sheet that is associated with a specific, um,
Google form, right, where it stores the results from the Google form and get that original URL,
uh, for the form. So you can make more submissions. And I just thought that this was such an excellent
example of understanding how your targets, your target security model and your threat model works,
right? Um, because I think if you're not intimately familiar with Google drive and what you should,
or what you should not be able to see, then you wouldn't, wouldn't know that you're not supposed
to be able to get the form associated with a given spreadsheet that contains the results of that form.
Um, so the researcher here dove really deep, understood the threat model really well,
and was rewarded with a $7,500 bounty for this finding. Um, and essentially what he did was he took the,
the, uh, document ID from, uh, the, the resulting spreadsheet and he created another spreadsheet and
added an app script to that. Excuse me. My voice is getting a little raspy.
Um, he, um, he took the document ID and put it inside of a app script function in a spreadsheet
that he does own and have editor access on and used the spreadsheet app dot open by ID function
to open up the ID of the, um, spreadsheet that he had read access on, but not owner and edit
and called the get form URL function on that specific, um, spreadsheet. And that returned to the,
the form that the user was not supposed to have access to. So I just thought that this was such an
awesome attack vector scenario, right? Using this, um, app script language in the functions in that
language to test invalidate that they're implementing the threat model surrounding who should have access
to what properties of a Google sheet correctly. Um, and I just thought that was awesome. And so he,
he did that once here and got $7,500 for it. And then he did it one more time over here. Um,
so it was December, 2024, and he got $15,000 for this one, which is nuts. And this one is very similar,
just does the exact same flow flow, grabs the, um, document ID from the read only document,
and then passes it into an app script on a, on a document that he does own and calls the get editors
function to get a list of people who have edit rights to the specific document. And apparently
if you have read only right to a document, you shouldn't be able to see the email addresses,
uh, and users, uh, information of the other editors on the doc. So this one actually dumped back emails,
uh, and, and stuff like that, usernames, um, which Google, uh, considers pretty valuable information.
And so this was a really awesome find. I just, I love that model. And, you know,
for any of you Google hackers there, I'm sure this guy went through and totally milked all of this.
And you should definitely not look for any of the ones that he missed using app script. And you
should also definitely not diff the app script docs to make sure when new functions are added,
that you can't be abused to do something similar. I think that's probably a waste of time
because this guy definitely found everything as all testers do.
All right, let's go ahead and move to the next one. Ooh, a little bit of water popped out there
and got on my glasses. All right, let's go to the next one. Um, let's see right here.
Okay. This was another writeup, uh, that actually only got $500, which I was a little bit disappointed
on. Um, but I kind of wanted to talk on it cause it was relevant to a, uh, sort of topic I wanted
to discuss with you all. Um, so let me first dive into it and, and, and then tell you what's gonna,
what's happening. So the title for this one is cloud tools for clips, chaining, misconfigured
OAuth callback redirection with open redirect vulnerability to leak Google OAuth token with full GCP
permissions, which one sounds sick. So, uh, Mr. Mo sucker that, uh, reported this, you rock. Um,
but essentially the TLDR of this one is with Google OAuth in this specific, um, environment,
you could redirect to, uh, a local host essentially, which is something that we often see in, uh, OAuth flows,
you, that the, either like a default URI that is approved is, uh, any port on local host, um,
or, you know, specific client IDs have started local host and on any port, you know, opened up,
um, as available for a redirect URI. Um, and what this guy did is he actually went and found a product
from Google that listens on port, um, on this port that was allowed port 8080, and then found an open
redirect in that product and chained it together. Right? So they can't say like, Oh, well, if you
have local host, uh, you know, access to catch the, the callback, then you already have the device owned
or whatever, right? They, they, they have to take responsibility for their own tool that was, had an
open redirect on that specific, uh, URL import, and then sort of chain that all the way through. Um,
so I thought that was brilliantly done by the researcher here. And it also made me think of another
attack vector that sort of, uh, was recently came to my attention with regards to local host redirects
for OAuth, uh, callbacks. And that is that when you are on mobile, on a mobile device, um, you, any app
on that device can listen to any port above 1024 without any additional permissions, right? So you can
just have an Android mobile app that just binds to port 8080 and then gets a callback from these specific,
uh, OAuth, uh, callbacks that allow access to port 8080 or local host, whatever port. Right. Um,
and I, and so I had a friend recently that popped that out and submitted it to a program and it got
informative because you were having an app on the device, which is just so dumb and I'm not going to
name and shame the program. I'm going to give them some time to like do their thing. But, um, yeah,
I was pretty disappointed by that outcome because you cannot just let every other app on the device
have access to your account, right? Like that's not okay. Um, so I think that this is a very valid
attack vector and I think that it was really easy, surprisingly easy with cursor and such to pock that,
um, script that creates the mobile app and, uh, catches the OAuth code. So definitely, um, something you
guys want to be on the lookout for. Um, all right. So that was all I had for the, uh, the Google write
ups. Uh, definitely some cool ones there. There are some other good ones there. I just didn't decide.
They just weren't as like broadly applicable to everybody. Um, so I grabbed those three just
because I thought they were like, this is a really cool, um, way to approach a target for the first one.
And then, you know, obviously the callback to local host stuff is just really applicable to so many
programs. All right, last one guys. And then I'm going to go chill. It is Sunday. Um, so I normally
try to take Sunday pretty chill, but this week was crazy with the wedding. So, all right. Um, this next
piece of research, uh, is by zero web sec zero with an H Z H E R O. Maybe it's Z hero. I don't know.
Kind of a cool name. Um, but they, uh, also did some research before I jump into this one,
the next JS and the corrupt middleware. They also did some other research earlier this year that
released in January on, um, uh, web cache stuff, uh, for, uh, next JS, which actually I don't see
in there. Oh, it's under the research tab on their website. Yeah. Right here. So, uh, they,
they've been kind of pwning JavaScript based frameworks for a little while.
This is the one I was thinking of right here, next JS cache and chains, the steel elixir. Um,
so there's, there's lots of good research here if you're interested in Nuxt or next JS. Uh,
so definitely go check that out. But this one in particular, who I thought was hilarious
because the payload is so simple. Um, so the researcher, um, kind of went through the next
JS source code. It was looking at middleware and apparently deep within the code of, uh, the next
JS middleware, there is this, uh, blob of code that checks the X dash middleware dash sub request header.
And if this header contains, uh, a specific string, then it will just skip all the middleware.
Lovely. Right. And the reason that they created this was, uh, as the researcher noted in the writeup
so that there isn't like an infinite loop of middleware, right? If the middleware sends a request
to another, you know, route on the application, then it's not just going to infinitely loop on the
middleware. Um, so that's cool. I like that. Uh, but the way that they implemented it was so funny.
It was like, okay, X middleware sub request. And then the value for it is like the path of the,
where the middleware lives, uh, which is like extremely predictable in, in this, uh, next JS environment.
Uh, because at the time of there was only like one router that exists, the pages router and your
middleware had to be placed underneath that in underscore middleware. Um, so the, this payload
right here, X middleware dash sub request, uh, with the value of pages slash underscore middleware
was all you needed to bypass any middleware, which is often very often where, um, authentication
or authorization checks are being done. Um, so that was a great find by the researcher here.
Uh, and that this specific, uh, exploit affects, um, versions before 12.2, but there after 12.2,
there's a different exploit, uh, that is required because of, uh, the, the middleware code getting
moved around, uh, which is this one with that in mind, the payload for the first version, starting
with version, uh, 12.2 is very simple. X middleware dash sub request, Coleman middleware,
right. Just super easy to tack on there. And then, uh, there's another variant where it could be in
the sources directory. So source slash middleware, um, really awesome, awesome stuff that they, that
they have here. They built out all of the different paths. There are a couple of edge cases as well,
where you might need to repeat your payload, uh, across different versions. But, uh, this I feel like
is massively exploitable in a bug bounty environment. Um, and they did go through and, and milk it on some
bug bounty programs, uh, as they said in the article. Um, obviously the, the biggest impact would be,
you know, auth bypass here and you can access some routes that are, should be protected.
But they also mentioned that oftentimes CSP headers, uh, are implemented in middleware. So you can use it
to bypass CSP and get that version cached, or you can do DOS by a cache poisoning as well. Um, if there is
sort of, uh, uh, a rewrite that was happening in the middleware for various like location-based stuff.
Um, uh, and so really, really great finds here, very thorough. Um, and yeah, I think it's really
applicable to bug bounty. I think any of you recon boys out there, uh, that can do mass scanning may
want to sort of look for those, uh, 403 endpoints that are coming back from, uh, next JS middleware,
and then try to tack on like a few variants of the payloads that are in this, uh, write up to,
to try to bypass off in those environments. Um, so, all right, I think that's about all I had from
the research for this week. Let me see if there's anything else. We do have a fun episode planned for
next week when Rezo gets feeling back better. Um, so we'll, I'll save most of the stuff that I had
planned for that for the next time around. Um, I guess as I'm closing out here, I will say,
would love to see all of you guys in the critical thinking discord. We've got a really awesome community
over there, especially in the critical thinkers. Um, we've got some fun masterclasses up. We've got
some hack along scheduled. Um, and then we've also got the full-time hunters guild for any of you guys
who are doing this full time. That's been particularly helpful for me. I've essentially
said to UG who's, uh, who's the community manager here at critical thinking, Hey, I want you to run
this and I'm going to be a member of the full-time hunters guild. Cause that's what I need. And so I've
just kind of been chilling and, you know, I'll, I'll pop in and do like the meet and greets and stuff like
that, but I've mostly been using the full-time hunters guild as like an accountability thing for
me and collaborating with some of the other hackers there. And I can personally say it's been really
helpful. So, um, for any of you full-time hunters that are listening, I would love to see you in that
definitely apply. You can find the application at ctbb.show slash full-time hunters guild FTHG,
right? Slash FTHG for full-time hunters guild. Um, all right, that's a wrap on this week. Love you guys.
See you next week. And that's a wrap on this episode of critical thinking. Thanks so much for watching to the end,
y'all. If you want more critical thinking content, uh, or if you want to support the show, head over
to ctbb.show slash discord. You can hop in the community. There's lots of great high level hacking
discussion happening there on top of the masterclasses, hack alongs, exclusive content, and a full-time
hunters guild. If you're a full-time hunter, it's a great time. Trust me. I'll see you there.